family waiting I got no in the big I'm
just a [ __ ] working honest enough in
again oh my god oh my god what is wrong
my co-star when it is in the chat hi
Glennis when it is Oh time she she knows
Tyler and it's highs birthday guys 34
years old looking good he ain't gotta be
up in the office
whoever will be to accomplish most of
our ownership and leverage a theory
Texas out of everything go speak to the
ones that have won the game who have
been able to play the patient's game and
let it come to them and go speak to the
ones that are no longer here whether by
their choice or our choice and all I
just know 80% of them regret not holding
their breath you know another six months
I mean this this is constantly this
arbitrary like self-esteem wrapped up in
title play like it just it makes no
sense when you've got everything going
for you and you're literally willing to
change the course of your life and
career because I've been patients on a
six or 12 months trajectory he's good
thank you
thing
what's up Instagram Manor nation if you
are available on June 28th and you want
to take your business or personal brand
or organization to the next level
we've started this four DS program email
me at Gary at vaynermedia comm Gary at
vaynermedia calm and I will have Tyler
forward the emails to the group here and
we'll get on the call
we'll get on the phone today and give
you the answers to the details we've
also got a video that um that uh has
nice little highlight reel to to the
four DS the daily digital deep dive is a
one day immersion into digital marketing
the way that we do it here at Vayner
retail if you have behind-the-scenes
look at where we operate we're going to
introduce everyone to the different
department heads these folks come
together to share both the tools and
tips that sets them apart of the
marketing space the best content will
always provide a personal value as
adaptive animal people have sort of
changed their habits and their behaviors
as well as what they've learned from
Gary I knew what he was really saying to
me as culture is always created from the
top down or other things that are kind
of the intangibles of what made us
Boehner so what you just watched is our
sizzle reel for four DS my email is
right here right now Gary at vaynermedia
just the quad part is worth $10,000 for
your business I just genuinely believe
that we gotta go goose why are you such
a dick
time oh let's have Tyler have a job well
you should have Ty's jobs me now from
your perspective Nate who's better at
this job you were tied it's a little bit
world I know but what but what do you
think deep down you right okay get in
time you except you ever want to have
that job will not based on that whole
August July oh my god oh my god what is
wrong my my co-star Gweneth is in the
chat hi when it when it is otaku she
knows Tyler and it's Hyde's birthday
guys 34 years old looking good - I love
you the world gets to see our stuff soon
love you so much miss you see you soon I
hope okay gotta go because Tyler's being
mean love you email me if you're
interested in a 4d well I'll get these
two handsome men on the phone with you
right away one if I love you're lucky
when we laugh to the tempo when I pick
something except both to the chef hold
an event fo but the man go with a GoPro
to compare go with a bag order the bag
of armies imagine or not sauce to know
we're coming
guys are you my sister Avenger answer
such a pleasure
how are thanks but that's it good I'm
super well great anything any value I
can bring you guys in these in this
quick 5-minute mean Brie
honestly I've uh this is one thing out
some on Tyler's I don't really have an
agenda
leave Gary other than cleaning context
right yeah I just think you bring a
message to a lot of people that is
massively valuable and you've been
obviously giving a lot of direction to
myself knowing people so my mom as you
are so we just like one of the things
I'm in the city and I am just wanting to
make you know me what I get it like that
would that would be my move right build
on context especially you have nothing
that you necessarily really need the
best thing to do is just face the name
handshake you build you never know how
like we may talk in 27 years from today
like I plan on being around and doing
[ __ ] you know so I get it I appreciate
it I'm glad you're here I have a energy
you I'm working like
our weeks at the office like trying to
build something like [ __ ] I don't have
like like that direction then order
right yeah it's like I hope there'd be
like where I would go yeah so I think I
think that's a good question I think and
I think I think one of the reasons I've
won is that I didn't stress about that
outside of buying the New York Jets when
I was building wine library we started
vaynermedia there you know I had a
general idea of like here's
vaynermedia's thesis if I scaled me and
what I'm good at
good things will happen I knew nothing
about the advertising industry I didn't
know exactly what good things meant so
little things I would tell you is that
you don't [ __ ] yourself on what am i
working towards what's my strategy
especially not at this age the number
one thing you should focus on is to get
as many powerful and smart people within
your company and in the city of Detroit
to know that you have that energy that
is far more powerful than anything you
can imagine
make sure Dan Gilbert's mafia in Detroit
regard boyfriend great make sure they
all know got it fit that is ROI positive
like people in the game all my friends
and contemporaries wanted to change the
world as a disguise to become rich and I
think I'm going about the other way I on
paper seem quite you know narcissistic
and things of that nature to do the
reverse yeah which is really rad I'd
much rather start off as the selfish
self promoter Barnum & Bailey Billy Mays
character who actually did the right
thing got it such a pleasure
yeah what's your nature man real
pleasure
excited Fergana I am gonna spend some
time with a bunch of team members now
that I think we're on the dawn of
becoming the creative AOR because that's
what I think is happening right like our
perspective is we're going to be below
the line we think that Facebook
commercials are television commercials
we think that everybody will trade on
that currency in 24 to 36 months and we
think we're going to be the dislike but
you know the compounded you know impact
them like I just generally think we are
that shop when this all plays out
because we're going to have the five
years of being that loud that proud that
good at it I mean the videos we're
making right now we finally are actually
making output to my hyperbole and now if
we can and we know we will now the tough
easy parts ahead of us tough part was
getting there we are going to produce
fifty five hundred examples of Facebook
commercials not television commercials
that are going to do well in the work is
starting to really matter so like the
entire above-the-line creative TV sees
for the entire summer originated as
Facebook Herschel's Facebook is so
special because it's Google meets
television yeah yeah and what that rule
is when I figured it out in 2000 as a
kid 2001 or two and grew my business in
which I spent more on Google that's what
so much drives we go so hardened to you
is a my regret of not building a to of
you've heard that you feel for me
here's a different I just have glean
letters that said silver oak Cabernet
you know the vulnerability to Facebook
is the creative part which is why but
it's so powerful because on the flip
side the reason people like where's the
beef and just do it is the creative part
I mean it's so special what you guys are
actually sitting on if you're able to
hit the crescendo moment of keeping the
attention of the world still in your
feed and the market catching up to what
we already know it makes you $150 stock
price look like the best buy in the
world I can sit and listen to every
[ __ ] story from 1958 engine seized to
1991 agent what you learned from other
people and what you guys live for the
rest of my life right it's the biggest
value on
I love that sure murder and we look I'm
getting goose bumps it's how I make
decisions on the flip side I know what
your writing is and I know it's better
than anybody on earth and I think I can
help and I like that situation yeah have
a great day thank you
[Music]
I am coming up a red-eye right to a
bunch of meetings right to the airport
and now this long flight to Ghana Justin
I don't know what you have for this
episode but I said biking tsukamoto
this is just a lady describing from
really super well everybody's trying
really hard hope everybody's trying to
figure themselves out because once you
figure it out
it'll happen the grad shooters a couple
everyone way let me to
[Music]
you